et donc allez vas-y ivan à lagord
catherine mon petit a acheté by the son
nouveau bull terrier en juillet 2020
elle l'a payé 2500 $ parce que c'est un
chien rare il est devenu le meilleur ami
de son fils j'ai pas d'autre enfant fax
élever son petit frère que le soir il va
l'aborder dans son lit n'écoute la télé
enfants mais c'est partout partout et
bon chien balle je fais partie des deux
cents mille nouveaux chiens et chats qui
ont été achetés par les québécois
pendant la première année et demie de
pandémie c'est pour les allemands la
présence que ces faits dans la maison
mais pose mes heures de dîner je viens
dehors évêques je veux marcher dans
leurs en arrière avec quasiment à tout
les jours selon un récent sondage
commandé par l'association des médecins
vétérinaires du québec
cinquante deux pour cent des ménages
québécois ont maintenant un chat ou un
chien c'est un record
claudia sauver la vétérinaire de base
seraient débordés
si j'ai vraiment jamais connu ça en
faisant carrière d'abord des temps
d'attentes pour les rendez-vous pour eux
cinq près stérilisation avant de
s'affaler dans la semaine du film mais
n'en faut se prendre des mois d'avancé
on va commencer
les familles sont moins nombreuses
qu'avant il y en a certains qui ont même
pas d'enfant avec l'événement ça fait
partie de la famille c'est leur enfant
dont sont beaucoup plus simples il veut
vraiment donner des soins
à la fin de mon elle a vu partir
plusieurs fois même s'il n'a pas encore
deux ans à l'extrait les deux canines
dubois invités qui avaient des problèmes
à long terme donc ça c'était une
intervention assez de soleil ou la
castration prix tout dernièrement au
mois d'octobre elle avait découvert un
souffle au coeur donc elles viennent pas
son électrocardiogramme pour qui tout
tourne mais catherine avait acheté une
assurance médicale qui lui coûte 90
dollars par mois pour son chien de plus
en plus de québécois jugent nécessaire
d'en prendre une j'ai déjà eu déjà des
factures d'un an laissant spécialisés
les gens font vraiment prête avait pas
fait beaucoup beaucoup plus de karak et
pas seulement pour les soins médicaux
à l'hôtel la grange de mirabel la
journée est assez tranquille cet hiver
les chiens sont souvent deux fois plus
nombreux lagrange un peu comme un cpm
offre service de pension canine les
affaires n'ont jamais été aussi bonnes
et lé travail nous amener beaucoup de
garderie de l'eau parce que le lâcher
passe la journée dans la maison face à
alan pêche le propriétaire de travailler
comme il veut aller re marié
deux fois par semaine lille hibernant
vient il essaie comme son os qui est ont
finement faire en sorte qu une présence
se fait et sécurisant et c'est très
réconfortant aussi alors moi je ne
portais quand ici parce qu'il ya besoin
de bouger ici passent la journée dehors
avec des amis donc tous socialistes
il dépend de son énergie elle paie 30 $
pour le faire garder toute la journée 50
$ si c'est pour la nuit à ses yeux le
bien-être de cole n'a pas de prix moi je
trouve pas que c'est trop justement
parce qu'un membre de la famille s'est
comptée dans un budget alors la
nourriture est compté les dépenses au
niveau des loisirs comme on ferait pour
aller faire du ski par exemple 6 et 5
étoiles des planchers chauffants
des chiens ils ont aujourd'hui eau
fraîche à tous les jours il ya une belle
enclos lagrange offre d'autres services
comme un massage orthopédique de 30
minutes à 20 dollars on a des chiens qui
sont plus âgés puis les gens sont prêts
à payer pour qu'on les fasse un petit
massage pendant le séjour
mais savez-vous une formation pour ça
c'est des gens qui vient non ça va être
plus choisi rennes période de tendresse
et caresse le
côté le museau à montréal avait été
précurseur en 2007 en offrant la pension
pour chiens et chats quatorze ans plus
tard la pandémie continue de lui amener
de nouveaux clients un vent 20 pour
salades à elle des demandes
d'informations et linda zago a
diversifié son offre muzeau propose par
exemple un cours de fitness avec
entraîneur caennais c'est qu'on
travaille sur l' équilibre sur le tonus
musculaire on muscle des endroits qui
n'ont pas l'habitude de travailler
ou bien un service de garde enrichi là
il ya des activités qui justement
travail un peu plus le mental le chien
alors il ya des jeux qui est font appel
au comité fond physique à l'éducation et
la journée est segmenté à dans les
petits ateliers l'aco vite sourit aussi
à daniel filion fondateur d'éducateurs
une entreprise qui donne des conseils
sur le comportement des chats et on est
passé de 2 à peu près 400 350 à 400
consultations à 500 600 consultations en
une année donc c'est du jamais vu comme
la majorité des nouveaux adoptants ce
sont des premiers adoptants qui ont
jamais eu d'animaux quand jamais eu de
chien ils sont pas très très haut
courade quels sont les besoins du show
et donc ils vont se retrouver avec des
problèmes de miaulements la nuit on voit
beaucoup sur le dénigrement la nuit des
problèmes depuis pillon laitière les
problèmes d' agression scellé 3 grosse
problématique qu'on a
de 2020 à 2021 le tour de ménage avec un
chat au québec serait passé de 31 à 36 %
la province compte maintenant deux
millions 134000 chat soit presque deux
fois plus que deux chiens aux
statistiquement parlant on le voit c'est
80 % de la clientèle des chocs qui sont
des femmes donc on voit beaucoup ça où
les fans ça devient leur enfant ça
devient un membre de la famille à part
entière son travail l'amène aussi à
évaluer certains produits pour chats
c'est ce qu'on appelle des bornes
interactives donc ça oblige le chat a
travaillé donc pour accéder à sa
nourriture et doit sortir la nourriture
des accessoires parmi tant d'autres au
québec l'offre de produits pour chats et
chiens explose depuis un creux vide
c'est tout les semaines la nouveauté
tous les semaines ça peut être dans les
jouets dans les laisse dans les
vêtements la nourriture les cannes tout
tous les domaines des nouveautés la
chaîne pas tes griffes vont maintenant
jusqu'à 35% plus de produits dans ses
magasins on a plusieurs propriétaires de
franchises en ce moment qu'ils ont
quitté leur emploi pour pouvoir investir
dans un paragraphe quand vous sortez de
6 a fait des choix une grosse facture
oui parce que je suis ok combler ça peut
vous rejetez la femme
en lice et
à eux seuls les aliments pour chiens
chats représentait au canada en 2020 un
marché de 4 milliards 200 millions de
dollars on est rendu à l'étape on veut
pas juste bien nourrir notre animal mais
le nourrit comme un membre valoriser de
la famille chez mondou qui va bientôt
compter 80 magasins au québec la
diversité des aliments impressionne
c'est ça c'est un produit dans le soja
lille si on a des côtes de boeuf en a
qui souvent ils vont acheter seulement
nourrir l'animal avec ça il y en
ad'autres choses et on veut donner une
petite gâterie un repas spécial ce son
anniversaire des biscuits à la noix de
coco aux bleuets ou au beurre d'arachide
des croquettes pour les articulations
pour la peau pour les dents ou pour
calmer les animaux n'ont rien à envier
aux humains sur les tablettes
et va être là parce que les gens vont
vouloir donner à leur animal de
compagnie la même chose que eux ils vont
manger est-ce que lara demande
accompagnant notre besoin le trois
quarts du temps non
tiens et chats perçus comme des enfants
la spa vient même de créer un contrat de
garde en cas de séparation
rappelant qu'une relation avec un animal
dure souvent plus longtemps qu'avec un
conjoint